on a une mission de césène donc on
habite dans un presbytère ça c'est pas
la mission la plus compliquée qu'on ait
à faire comme à d'autres missions qui
sont de faire de l'aumônerie des
animations de metz et puis préparer au
baptême on sait là pour ça qu'on aime à
ce fort si on a quatre enfants qui ont
entre 6 ans et 7 ans et demi et deux ans
je me suis en principe affirmé mais j'ai
pris un congé parental pour m'occuper
des enfants
et moi je suis ingénieur le soir la
lettre
vous allez écrire à se présenter et
demandé à être confirmée la difficulté
en aumônerie c'est qu' il n'y a pas
forcément le répondant qu'on aimerait
avoir
souvent et que jenny on s'aime et puis
on verra bien ce qui
met voilà ce qui pousse c'est pas
forcément immédiatement et ses impôts là
la difficulté
je joue de la bomba qui est un
instrument breton il se trouve que dans
un village à côté là j'ai un ami qui
joue de la cornemuse et donc s'est dit
tiens si on monte des petits concerts de
temps en temps bombarde cornemuse donc
on a fait ça ici et puis est venue se
greffer à ce concert un ami de jean de
la mairie qui chante on a fait le
concert avec lui et après il m'a dit il
ya repas des personnes âgées là est ce
que ça te dirait pas d'animer avec me
suis retrouvé à l'auberge de l'abbaye
qui est juste en face là
avec tout le club des personnes âgées de
neauphle le vieux a chanté pas le même
registre que ce que je peux chanter à la
messe est dite
j'ai trouvé il fait le lien entre les
différents foyers d'accueil c'est
vraiment d'être un foyer chrétien dans
une ville dans un village montré que
peut être jeune chrétien est heureux
d'être chrétien c'est ça la première
forme de témoignage à lescar cette
mission on l'a reçue par un couple
d'amis qui la vit aussi dans la ville de
thoiry et fait quand ils nous ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient vivre cette
mission ils nous ont décrit ce qu'ils
allaient faire et tout de suite ça nous
a fait tilt 20 de ses sorties appelés à
vivre la même chose et c'est là que nous
indique à neauphle-le-vieux il cherche
éventuellement un couple un couple
disponible avec voilà qui serait prêt à
déménager à emménager dans ce presbytère
donc on a pu contacter le curé on a pu
contacter le le diocèse et puis petit à
petit on a réussi à s'installer la
première fois qu'on l'a visitée enfin on
a vu que c'est une maison à quitter
ancien complètement accolé à l'église on
savait déjà qu'on aurait peut-être une
vie de prière différente par rapport à
ce qu'on avait avant on savait aussi ce
serait un lieu d'accueil mine de rien
même si on n'accueille pas tous les
jours des personnes on savait que des
personnes ne seraient susceptibles de
venir toquer à la porte produits pour
des renseignements
parce qu'ils avaient besoin de quelque
chose dans cette paroisse ciel va donc
il fallait quand même qu'on arrive à
avoir un lieu accueillant par exemple
dans le salon on a vraiment mis 28 à
sainte vierge bien visibles pour entrer
voilà on a une famille comme toutes les
autres mais une famille chrétienne
quelque chose qui s'est passé pendant
les quatre années il bute prière qui
s'est installée parce qu'il fallait
porter la miction mais qu'il fallait
vraiment content confié au seigneur
parce que toutes émissions qu'on a là
c'est pas des missions qu'on a choisi sa
démission qu'on nous a proposé de fait
les enfants vivent avec nous dans cette
mission là donc il fallait leur montrer
que le seigneur était présent au coeur
de cette mission et du coup ça nous a
donné une régularité dans la prière ça
c'est quelque chose qui va rester
j'espère
moi je m'occupe de la mission le soir et
les week-ends puisque la journée je suis
pris travaille dans une société qui fait
des plans pour la construction des
méthaniers le transport du gaz liquide
saint rémy les chevreuse et comment vous
en parler au travail j'ai changé de
travail entre temps là où j'étais avant
en fait ça s'est fait assez simplement
j'ai demandé de l'aide
à mes collègues pour qu'ils puissent
venir m'aider à déménager dans le
presbytère avant qu'on puisse l'éviter
des coups je leur ai demandé s'ils
voulaient pas venir me donner un coup de
main et ils sont arrivés ici il se fait
que c'était un presbytère c'est vrai que
du coup ça a amené beaucoup de
discussions aussi sur la manière dont on
vit sa foi la manière dont on peut
s'engager aussi la première question
c'est de savoir comment j'allais faire
avec trois enfants plus le travail plus
tout le reste sachant qu'il ya eu un
quatrième depuis j'aurai un petit peu
expliqué que dans cette mission il y
avait trois vies en une seule la vie au
travail la vie des bains et du dîner le
soir et puis la vie des réunions ans
après et puis que c'était aussi mission
à durée déterminée donc je me donne à
fond pour cette mission pendant un temps
donné et puis après on verra